the uni party's border sneak that's the
focus of tonight's
angle the uni party in Washington is
really talented at hiding the ball now
for several weeks we've heard about the
so-called bipartisan border bill that
were told by people like Senator James
Langford will provide powerful tools to
address the crisis at the border and
even though sources have told me that
the important Provisions were finalized
weeks ago
the key players want to pretend that
there's still a lot of last minute give
and take happening I'm here tonight to
tell you do not believe a word of that
because the overriding goal is not
securing the Border here Biden could
have done that on day one the real goal
that Mitch McConnell and Chuck Schumer
care about is to get that $60 billion
more for Ukraine which McConnell thought
would be easier if they tied it to new
immigration
legislation had a lot of discussion
obviously about the border around here
but it's important to focus on the other
rationale for the
supplemental hopefully we can work this
border issue out in a way that's
satisfactory but there's bipartisan
support here in the senate for both
Israel and
Ukraine the truth is the Senate is not
keeping the so-called border bill secret
because it's tough on enforcement and
ends things like parole and catch and
release they're keeping the bill secret
because they don't really want to defend
it over any significant amount of time
in front of any big audiences certainly
not in their home districts has Senator
Langford who's been quarterbacking this
had a town hall in
Oklahoma why not to try to explain to
his constituents why any Republican
should allow Biden to claim a border
Victory here how is this tough on
enforcement when Biden still has the
authority to wave in close to 2 million
migrants every year under this so-called
negotiated border agreement now these
fossils in the Senate think Americans
are naive or stupid or
both we are getting very close on the
National Security Supplemental we cannot
simply Sherk from our responsibilities
just because a task is difficult we plan
to post the full text of the National
Security Supplemental as early as
tomorrow
no later than Sunday leading to the
first vote on the National Security
Supplemental no later then
Wednesday okay so think about this
classic swamp move right release what
200 300 400 page Bill late on a Friday
or over the weekend you know it's not
coming till Sunday then you force a vote
on it just a few days later now they
wouldn't buy a car with with this little
information they'd look under the hood
they test it out
right but they're going to do it with
this Senator Mike Lee smashed this in an
oped published today saying the law firm
of Schumer and McConnell Spends months
drafting legislation in complete secrecy
let's members see Bill Tex for the first
time only a few a few days sometimes a
few hours before an arbitrary deadline
then forces a vote in the legislation on
or before that deadline denying Senators
any real opportunity to read digest and
debate
the measure on its
merits this is not just a cram down this
is a sham any serious uh anyone who is
serious about passing a border Bill and
not just scoring political points for
Biden would have kept the house Speaker
Mike Johnson in the loop all all along
frankly they would have made sure that
he was on board otherwise what's the
point Langford and Schumer In Cahoots
did not do this very telling Johnson has
effectively said said the bill is DOA in
fact 64 House Republicans are demanding
that Joe Biden use his executive
Authority ASAP to address this border
crisis but in pretending new
legislation's needed the White House and
the Senate GOP leadership is effectively
giving the same message to the American
people as those vicious migrants in New
York yeah the middle
finger this is a complete farce and now
even house Democrats apparently are
threatening to torpedo the bill heck of
a job Mitch and Chuck Nice going well
come on guys Americans see the truth
here they're becoming strangers in their
own land as criminal migrants are able
to fly around the country using only a
piece of paper as ID and they're growing
Bolder like those Venezuelan thugs in
New York these individuals I went over
their wrap sheets yesterday multiple
charges Grand larsy robbery attempted
robbery grand larsy grand larsy uh this
particular crew operated on mopeds and
scooters they were doing organized
retail theft they've only been here a
couple of months so what the detectives
are telling me is they have Crews here
that operate in New York do all their
stealing then go to Florida to spend the
money and then come back and I'm like
well why don't they just stay and steel
in florid and they said because there
you go to
jail yeah the anchor is like what well I
wasn't ready for that answer yeah
consequences in Florida oh and speaking
of consequences there needs to be
consequences political consequences for
Republicans trying to force this bill
nine months before the election let the
people decide this pro-amnesty
Republicans though when you really think
about it would be really happy if this
new border bill hamstrung president
Trump from really shutting down the
border and really deporting people if he
wins in November
the former president calls us a betrayal
is that a what do you think of that
characterization it's certainly not a
betrayal it hasn't been released how
does he know it's a betrayal if he
hasn't read it I mean don't be ignorant
read the
Bill Cassidy is the absolute worst he's
a big spending disaster and dimwit we
can't read the bill because y'all are
hiding it from the people but nice try
now we're going to stay on this and have
comprehensive analysis of the text when
this Kabuki theater really gets underway
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else